-Performing their #1 hit
"Heat Waves"
from their album "Dreamland,"
here is Glass Animals!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Sometimes,
all I think about is you ♪
♪ Late nights
in the middle of June ♪
♪ Heat waves
been fakin' me out ♪
♪ Can't make you happier now ♪
♪ Sometimes,
all I think about is you ♪
♪ Late nights
in the middle of June ♪
♪ Heat waves
been fakin' me out ♪
♪ Can't make you happier now ♪
♪ Usually I put
somethin' on TV ♪
♪ So we never think
about you and me ♪
♪ Today I see our
reflections clearly ♪
♪ In Hollywood,
layin' on the screen ♪
♪ You just need
a better life than this ♪
♪ You need somethin'
I can never give ♪
♪ Fake water
all across the road ♪
♪ It's gone now,
the night has come, but ♪
♪ Sometimes,
all I think about is you ♪
♪ Late nights
in the middle of June ♪
♪ Heat waves
been fakin' me out ♪
♪ Can't make you happier now ♪
♪ You can't fight it,
you can't breathe ♪
♪ You say somethin'
so lovin', but ♪
♪ Now I gotta let you go ♪
♪ You'll be better off
in someone new ♪
♪ I don't wanna be alone ♪
♪ You know it hurts me, too ♪
♪ You look so broken
when you cry ♪
♪ One more
and then I'll say goodbye ♪
♪ Sometimes,
all I think about is you ♪
♪ Late nights
in the middle of June ♪
♪ Heat waves
been fakin' me out ♪
♪ Can't make you happier now ♪
♪ Sometimes,
all I think about is you ♪
♪ Late nights
in the middle of June ♪
♪ Heat waves
been fakin' me out ♪
♪ Can't make you happier now ♪
♪ I just wonder
what you're dreamin' of ♪
♪ When you sleep
and smile so comfortable ♪
♪ I just wish
that I could give you that ♪
♪ That look that's
perfectly un-sad ♪
♪ Sometimes,
all I think about is you ♪
♪ Late nights
in the middle of June ♪
♪ Heat waves
been fakin' me out ♪
♪ Heat waves been
fakin' me out ♪
♪ Sometimes,
all I think about is you ♪
♪ Late nights
in the middle of June ♪
♪ Heat waves
been fakin' me out ♪
♪ Can't make you happier now ♪
♪ Sometimes,
all I think about is you ♪
♪ Late nights
in the middle of June ♪
♪ Heat waves
been fakin' me out ♪
♪ Can't make you happier now ♪
♪ Road shimmer
wigglin' the vision ♪
♪ Heat, heat waves,
I'm swimmin' in a mirror ♪
♪ Road shimmer
wigglin' the vision ♪
♪ Heat, heat waves,
I'm swimmin' in a ♪